Choose the right number of
each place value to make 8,129.
And we could say this
is 123 thousandths.
Or we could say it is 1 tenth,
2 hundredths, and 3 thousandths.
So let's just go place by place.
So first we have 8.
This 8 right over here is
in the thousands place.
It represents 8 thousands.
So we're going to
have 8 thousands.
So let's select 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8 thousands.
Then we have one 100.
So we literally just have
only one 100 right over there.
Then we have 2 tens.
This 20 is 2 tens.
So we're going to need 2 tens.
Then this 9, well,
that's just 9 ones.
So it's 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And now we're going
into the tenths place.
This is only 1 tenth.
So 1 tenth right like that.
Now this is 2 hundredths.
So we're going to put
2 hundredths there.
Then finally, 3 thousandths--
1, 2, 3 thousandths.
And we check our answer.
And we got it right.